what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch a movie that
I'm surprised I've never seen myself actually
1996's twister joined by Roxy schreier follow
her at the World Girls Channel she pressured
us into doing this hardcore just like I really
want to do twister because I'm working with
like a couple of people who worked on twister
I'm like fine shut up Roxy it's not not what
happened but it's also not what happened she
were working with who Sean is directing and
starring in this new movie crust that I'm
in and Alan is coming to pee in it also is
it about pizza because crust no it's a laundromat
thing and crust um more like a little more
raunchy than pizza crust question oh crusty
I got it I I got there it's a horror comedy
uh the word crust is more about socks leave
a like if you're excited for the movie crust
upcoming with Roxy and Alan Rick yeah Alan
rock you know he's a star of succession Ferris
Bueller's Day Off John whalen's been in everything
from Twister to Never Been Kissed stalked
by movie more full length Reaction watch along
three stick up with your own coffee or twister
available for super sexy rejects super sexy
rejects there you go I tried to do what jaundice
[Music] three is that what John does have
you not heard him do that oh he behaves very
different when it's you and him on camera
so I'm gonna try some bits out with Roxy today
I'm going to entertain her today
I don't know what you're doing
the concept of this movie had me thinking
how weather negatively affects our internet
thank you to nordvpn for sponsoring this video
a digital tool that'll have you browsing the
web like like a curious little kitty cat but
really what nordvpn is like is like having
a secret weapon that'll keep you safe while
exploring the vast wonders of the internet
think of it like a virtual bodyguard here
to protect you from all those lurking cyber
threats first things first nordvpn is the
fastest cat when it comes to the VPN surfaces
the whole range of services at its disposal
nordvpn not only ensures your protection but
also adds a dash to convenience to your Digital
Life oh it's speaking of protection nor VPN
unleash their threat protection feature which
blocks malware and keeps a watchful eye on
the mysterious dark web so if someone leaks
your precious credentials nor vpn's dark web
monitor will notify you they also have your
downloadables covered scans those files for
viruses faster than you can say kitty cat
and here's one of the best parts too nordvpn
lets you change your virtual location with
a single click sometimes I just do it for
fun that means you can watch content that
might be currently unavailable in your current
region or country there's a reason why I really
believe in the power of nordvpn I mentioned
it a few times on this channel a couple of
years ago we had a serious hacking situation
when it came to our account and guess what
we weren't using a VPN at the time a wake-up
call that led us to swear by the importance
of a solid reliable VPN so take it from us
get yourself a nordvpn just one account can
protect up to six devices and to Sweden the
deal too nordvpn offers a 30-day money-back
guarantee for all users so reject Nation to
experience the magic of norvpn click on the
exclusive deal linked Down Below in the pinned
comment or description box or you can just
go to visit nordvpn.com real rejects remember
it's risk-free with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee so stay safe stay secure and happy
virtual Adventures my friends
oh yes oh yes this was a good choice that's
live that's a 90s credit sequence of my head
I love it thank me later [Music] 69 69.
oh this this is gonna be fun
the flux capacitor yeah all right
have you ever seen a tornado in real life
yeah no have you no that'd be cool though
I'm from Boston I'm from I'm from down the
street
tornado
sounds like a guttural roar come on sweetie
let's get up come on we need to get down to
the storm right now oh that might be young
Helen yeah 100 Joe's about to lose her parents
yeah
parents deserve to die
oh no
I swear if this dog dies in the beginning
no oh what a messed up movie
you did a good movie Toby so close to Toto
it's an homage Greg also the Topher it's an
homage to Mr Grace yes and oh I love this
it's like it's a monster
whoa Papa
oh wow it's personal now that same tornado
is gonna come back in 30 years I'm gonna kick
this tornado's ass at least he didn't die
saving the dog that would have been a cooler
way to go out no that's a Man of Steel [__]
no that is not the same thing that guy is
Superman
you know if these cells keep building like
this there could be a record outbreak of tornadoes
this is going to be a long day what year are
we now uh present day so that would be 1996.
so from 69 to 96. yeah just flip the numbers
yeah it's uh artistic choice in the way that
you flip in a 69 so so do you get it I do
I've done sex stuff before
I know Joe she's already dragged her entire
department into the field
divorce I got it oops this thing is useless
sorry Joe mad about satellite
ah any TV reference you give bring it on um
[Music] is that Philip Seymour Hoffman all
I'm saying that's Sean John Whalen oh my God
I love both of these actors are the best part
of the movie you did a great job there
Philip Seymour Hoffman used to play so many
characters like this this is wild all right
Joy and Bill Paxton yeah yeah it's the biggest
serious storms in 12 years one lined up right
after another and SSL says they've never seen
anything like it this is how they catch up
about the divorce papers oh yeah yeah yeah
sure hey this shot oh man this is the guy
from Lost yeah he's in a lot of [__] yeah
you need them right this second well that'd
be nice yes this one's the urge and urgency
act like you're getting married I am that's
a tough twist in the heart there you go thank
you
oh she was still wearing it still wearing
what her wedding ring it's a blue I mean no
she put her non-wetting ring on top of her
yeah good catch can I read it first no it's
the same as it was in December I didn't read
it in December Christ would you just sign
it so we can get out of here we she's here
yes she's here she's over with Dusty go meet
her bill just told me the happy news we just
wanted to get it done before uh Billy started
his new job at weatherman what I said weather
man I think it's great yeah that tone there
was no tone if you have a problem being a
weatherman
I thought you'd be coming out here alone I
wasn't expecting on coming out here at all
you said you'd meet me at Dorothy she's here
is Dorothy the name of the Twister uh the
tornado Dorothy and Toto never mind that's
Dory I can't believe you did it we built four
of them cancel the divorce okay weather man
hey watch the tone Roxy whether this was that
better is better we put her up inside a tornado
and releases hundreds of these sensors that
measure all parts of the tornado simultaneously
wind velocities flow asymmetries we could
learn more in 30 seconds they have in the
past 30 years
how do you get it in the tornado well you
got to get in front of the tornado and put
it in the damage path and then get out again
before it picks you up too it's oh
Joe we got major action that SSL says the
cap is breaking Tower's going up 30 miles
off the dry line
come on man you're getting a divorce might
as well just one last tornado
he wants to get involved it's where his heart
is yeah but Dorothy did you sign papers oh
[__] she didn't come on free hurry we
can still catch him hey Bill glad you're back
I'm not back okay Bill keep telling yourself
that darling I'll get the paper signed and
see you tonight okay no you know what honey
I find this kind of interesting I'm gonna
tag along ah menajah not feeling like that's
the way it's gonna go I I think that's how
those things happen
oh yeah Jonas Miller he's a night crawler
oh my God you're down the same lab then Jonas
went out and got himself
competing tornado experts I love it
wow there's also vehicular Thrills what if
we predict tornado's patch how many lives
will be spared with creation of an early warning
system the first digital orthographic telemeter
dot three carry always let's go when released
to the tornado we'll transmit back data on
wind speed pressure what a bunch of [__]
for all study did he punch his hat off yeah
we both know he'll never get that thing up
in the air that's right let me Enlighten you
people today we're gonna make history because
the day's a sniffing the dirt are over he
reprized this character and say stranger things
season three it's like the exact same character
one day I'll give you one day whether she
flies or not I'm gone honey is it is it okay
oh God so boring Melissa well he hasn't really
told me about all this if you have to pee
you should do it now because there's not very
many places to stop once we get on the road
you're so in love with him aren't you Melissa
you became slightly interesting okay let's
move out people let's go where are we going
Melissa make yourself useful oh she's gonna
drive out no no
I knew it dumbass Melissa can't get anything
right I know she must be the most hated character
in cinematic history amazing coloring there
isn't it yeah look at those palmatas I bet
those tops have got to be spiking about 40
000. that's a good thing it's a very good
thing what uh something about science guy
yes she's very nice no she does not work at
the station she's uh she's a therapist yours
Christ
look I may have walked out but at least I
showed up in the first place
commitment like stability supportiveness in
a house dude can I drive no then would you
whoa vehicular action it was wild that was
such a 90s movie moment wow it would be so
cool to see this tornado sure not for people
who've actually seen this tornado they would
say that three miles Southeast let's see what
she does whoa that looks great for 96 damn
that looks very real go in there hurry
second that's your nerve tighten your seat
belt that was hot for some reason
[Music]
damn holy [__] this plant is ridiculous
you let her provoke you
that is a terrify accident what is the plan
here they gotta let it get caught into it
the the Earth thank you
they're just gonna stay right there that's
terrible idea
what are you doing
what do you want to see it's her childhood
trauma Greg she needs therapy
wow
no way they would not get caught up in that
oh they were totally get caught up in that
I don't even know how a tornado works but
I know they get caught him we don't know where's
my truck
yes do it oh God I'm okay let's try she's
screaming she's horrified she's traumatized
you could understand Helen hunts well I want
to look at the tornado up close but you can't
understand this yes analyze me later all right
yeah so something more about you the Auto
Club's here ah these snakes come on guys let's
get Dorothy two ready we got full coverage
on that truck liability only it's a very pretty
truck thank you
[Laughter] again but back there you almost
got yourself oh no just a close call you're
gonna cross 15 at Oklahoma 4-1-2 cinema four
one two baby
what are you doing what are you doing
cut through the field look at the updraft
the angle it's gonna shift his track it'll
move left is that bad wasn't there a road
back there you're right go go go go go I do
like how they used Melissa to be the audience
yeah
are you sure
it's moving away I know it feels unnatural
but with Donald's motility you're not gonna
have to save the old-fashioned way she's a
reproductive
therapists
gotta have American Heroes
I really do like how they capture the Twister
like it's a like it's a Monster yeah it's
really cool well it is scary as hell yeah
I know I bet I still am unclear on how they're
planning on getting this in they gotta put
it in the path so it just sucks it up in the
past right but like if you were gonna do that
it feels like the car situation was the perfect
situation to do that yeah that's what I thought
happened yeah but apparently not because they
didn't like unleash it when she went to go
back to try to you have to do something it
like spit out
apocalypse
there's double the tornadoes
okay we got sisters what's a water tornado
called probably just that yeah you probably
nailed it cyclon oh maybe yeah I'm not sure
oh get off the phone Melissa no the cow oh
wait I think I've seen that image before
oh [__]
wow what a terrifying situation
okay sweat is safe have you seen Smallville
yeah celebrate with your wife your actual
wife put your arm around do they get it up
are they celebrating because they did it I
think they're celebrating because they survived
okay it's okay no I'm not okay oh Christ I'm
sorry you used to tell me that you chased
tornadoes deep down I was just I was a metaphor
[Laughter] like skeletons in your closet that
was a metaphor some of us couldn't help but
notice how close we are to Wakita guys we
are not in
[Applause]
their dog and her mom well I think the dog
probably died because it's been like almost
30 years in a severe lightning storm you want
to grab your ankles and stick your butt in
here okay if you're gonna get hit it's the
safest orifice yeah I'd like to get hit by
lightning Watts you know true you could ask
him when you see him on set what was it an
F3 solid F2 it's the Fujita Scale it measures
the intensity of a tornado by how much it
eats encounter meat back there's a strong
F2 F3 maybe but we see someone for us today
is there an F5
oh Melissa it's took her dad none of you have
ever seen left five oh they will today she
has just one of us yeah
oh what a good moment there's a lot of good
actors in it mostly Alan and Sean they'll
they're the best he didn't keep his part of
the bargain to spend his life pining for you
and die miserable and alone got so much to
ask Helen Hunt is really good in this movie
yeah she's great Bill always went his own
way which was usually the same way you were
going it seems like a long time ago
tear is he there to get divorce papers
there's so many goddamn tornadoes you better
run
yeah it's the dog it's Dorothy grown-up no
the dog's name was Toto Toto no you said it
sounded like Topher and I said it sounded
like Toto it was a tobo toddy Teddy ah [__]
let us know Tata ask them when you see the
monster
Bill trust me rabbit is good gravity is wives
great line delivery excels at every line he
delivers agreed you see that brush right in
front of you what's beyond that it's the highway
it's the highway where's the road rabbit yeah
where's the road man it should be any moment
whoa [Applause] whoa oh my God you're insane
Joe what are you trying to do get somebody
killed
it was right okay they threw down for these
like Chase the tornado sequences yeah we're
gonna have to get off of this road but this
is no time to guess I'm not guessing just
make a right turn trust me do you want to
drive just turn he's gonna be a great weather
man looks like he's coming down room 33. what's
the path uh it's going about 35 miles an hour
okay let's see this
can't see it I believe that he couldn't see
it yeah me too you see it no you got anything
out there North Northeast [__] is coming
right at us do you see it no no he already
said he didn't see it where's Melissa um slowly
dying on the inside time for deployment guys
let's do it oh man this is the fun part sweetheart
no why she was getting stuck with him if I
was her you don't marry him now when someone
shows you who they are believe them and he's
neglecting her Sanders pull it over anywhere
so many weather choices yeah I'm pretty sure
Sean told me the movie was delayed months
because of all the actual weather stuff oh
and they need to actually control how it how
they shoot it yeah
some good sound design in this movie damn
so they're finally gonna do it
you guys are insane we need we know they have
four of these we know they've gone through
two now right so this is the third yes so
thematically this won't work because we need
to get to the fourth thematically or like
plot wise not thematically the opposite of
thematically expositionally sure structurally
structure [Music] if this is three what's
four or five it's the shape of a Kaiju monster
[Music]
[Music] I love in movies when they say things
like a hurry it's like yeah no [__] [Music]
it wouldn't work even if they just let it
take the truck I don't think he wants to lose
his truck liability [Music] oh no no not Dorothy
oh no no no no Dorothy no Dorothy where is
it oh my God it's gonna come from another
spot I don't believe this so late to getting
it because Dorothy got sucked into the tornado
I just put that together well Dorothy she's
okay she lives yeah but she in The Wizard
of Oz she goes into her tornado what kind
of isn't that how she gets to Oz we don't
need to go over this right now yeah and then
she wakes up yeah I think it knocks her out
I don't think she gets sucked up well there's
still a turtle I know something hits her she
goes in the cellar she's running away
it is too late honey she needs to understand
what took her parents her dad what are you
doing
oh you've never seen him miss this house and
miss that house and come after you Joe things
go wrong you can't explain it you can't predict
it killing yourself won't bring your dad back
sorry he died but it was a long time ago gotta
move on it's a great radio stop living in
the past and look at what you got right in
front of you solid radio connection oh my
God the mic on it I love love though
that was such a beautiful moment oh I'm sorry
Melissa but you're not it honey you're not
it when it's not you it's not you it's been
not me for many times I know it sucks but
it's not you it's not you do you know how
many guys Roxy has lost because of their obsession
with tornadoes yeah and the woman from the
tornado the list goes on and on
whoa what a weird shining what the hell it
is The Shining
oh she gotta sign the divorce papers Roxy
as she should you don't you don't want to
trap anybody in anything they don't want to
be in nah well that's your opinion
okay love is love that's what I say you know
I've been thinking about the sensors the way
they scattered out there today on the highway
I'm starting to wonder whether the funnel
will carry him like we thought too late I
don't know maybe the whole thing's too light
you talking about Melissa being too light
he's rethinking
now it's serious yeah let's take a TV television
the five the five is come for your
here's Johnny
it's
already here everybody underground now how
fun it would be to deliver lines like that
[Music]
sick great shot everybody
ouch oh that was sliced your face up
damn I love the sets
it's like the Universal Studios
holy [__] I'm not saying I wouldn't be
her but I hope I wouldn't be here Melissa
yeah screaming at the top of your lungs just
like treating it like she's the only one
no do not take my ant oh my God they're really
gonna do this that's cruel what is the end
goal here of this movie they're gonna like
learn what the tornado is yeah I was just
thinking that because we still have to I think
we still have like almost a half hour don't
we yeah I think so can you tell which way
it's headed back in Northeast it looks to
hit Wakita head on I'm going let's go away
you don't have your Dorothy sensor [__]
though no she does she's gotta go to her aunts
I'm going back good good he'll be safe at
the motel I'll see you in the morning I won't
be there I I can't compete with this wait
don't do this now please terrible timing
she's right I love her now best character
in the movie yep you go ahead she needs you
what about you don't worry about me I know
my way home now she dies it's okay because
yeah I still think they should kill her off
yeah me too but I now like her I'll now feel
sad yeah they rounded out all the Loose Ends
that we needed them to to feel good about
it like she signed the paper so we know she's
not trapping him they ended anyway with Melissa
like you know all the things that we needed
Spielberg did a great job directing that moment
I know it's philbrick is an excellent director
Josephina spilbert knew what she was doing
[Music]
no no
joke take a flashlight the dog
dog's alive we gotta get this off over hang
on oh God okay ready watch your hand watch
it go go why do you think they made this character
her aunt instead of her mom I'm not sure
yikes you gotta hurry let's go take a good
walk
whoa
[Applause]
great though he practiced where's the dog
you're going to the hospital
honey your car's in a tree around the corner
oh
honey I don't even know if you want to know
but I it's it's happened in NSS self predicting
an F5 you go stop it
you do stop it
he's telling her to go do the thing because
they have one left
I know how to make Dorothy fly okay plane
Superman I think if you take a plane you drop
it from above oh your guess was real or Dominic
Toretto would just zoom right past through
it come out the other end and tornado I need
every aluminum can you cutters so I want to
get the last door in the back of my truck
and I want to get them both on there right
now he was able to see what she wanted to
do without aluminum cans that's love
I would take an aw a root beer
a decade I haven't had real soda in a long
time what's fake soda sparkling water so like
bubblies that was the Sabbath sentence you've
ever said they're delicious they are good
just to satisfy this is how they're able to
pay for this whole movie yeah that one Pepsi
scene Dusty you ready for us yeah yeah we're
good do you know what they're doing they need
to make them fly because they said they were
too light they weren't going up oh yeah so
whatever those windmill like yeah so was not
a metaphor for Melissa could have been I figure
put it right in the middle of the road I think
somebody will hit it nobody will be there
somebody will hit it he's gonna drive like
all right let's go
the actual twister scenes are really well
done yeah
it's real like suspense
it was a lot simpler than any of the other
times
it's got to go wrong right Carrie Elvis foreign
oh [__]
whoa
oh my god oh I got goosebumps
did she say what is that yeah I believe it's
a tornado
oh shoot
damn oh no they do that
[Music]
oh they're in it now oh you can't survive
at F5
whoa whoa jeez nice
way to go bill this monster still moving Northeast
on Eddie this is it last one I thought that
we were on the last one all right no there's
another one in there yeah I saw it but remember
they said they had four
it's beautiful Carrie go away as you wish
you did it you made it work marriage okay
path is stable copy that hello
you get my father prepare to die that's what
she's saying to the Twister yeah that is true
you killed my father prepare to die Jonas
what's your position we are heading Northeast
running parallel and about to pull ahead of
it on the left why hang back a minute we got
a pretty good view from back here she could
shift her Dragon if she does she's gonna come
right after it when I want your opinion I'll
give it to you when I want your opinion I'll
give it to you listen to me this is not get
off this frequency Bill she's shifting oh
so they're going to be the ones who die
right for him
eliminated the competition
for 96 this looks awesome it looks amazing
still looks better than a lot of movies that
today
I think they have some of the actual items
they're destroying
drive right through it do it movie so he said
it looks like we're going yeah that's what
I'm talking about
oh hell yeah oh that was sick I love it let
me just set the cruise control okay we're
good oh they're gonna jump out of the car
like you suggested at the beginning yeah man
just how are you gonna get away from the tornado
I don't know why are they staying that
long
time ago you both could have he had it on
cruise control yeah there's no point of you
guys staying in there
oh yeah
little fireflies [Music]
sure wreck some more houses
there's just no way like should you like dig
a hole in the ground that will not do anything
hold on to the leaves I would not want to
be in a tornado position with you rocks right
[Music] oh my God like the beginning is there
an underground [Music]
[Laughter]
like does the house even slow it down
oh my God
where are we
good thing it's unlocked
we out here too we might have a chance we're
gonna hang on to the pipes
they're gonna tie themselves to the pipes
yep smart
oh my God I feel like pipes break all the
time not in this situation nope not when it's
Bill
while they're in the middle of it they should
have just kept Dorothy on them like a great
look
we're gone in that house
I do wonder if that pipe thing actually will
work in real life total [__] Dorothy really
flew I gotta get Grant approval for a new
warning system you've got to start analysis
and all that data I do yeah we got to generate
models out of all this dead and I need to
run the limbs I'm a weatherman I'm running
the lab you're right I don't think so do you
always have to do things the hard way
damn it Dusty and friends if you pull up and
your friends are alive you're probably stoked
we've seen enough
everyone's like well what about Melissa man
I feel like that leather strap would have
ripped through them probably that'd be gory
now I'm just making out Jen the bunt directed
it
back who's John de Bond oh my God Michael
Crichton wrote did you know Michael Crichton
is who is that he's the writer of a Jurassic
Park he wrote the book and he wrote the book
for Westworld Steven Spielberg oh that makes
sense his name sounds familiar I don't like
that you quizzed me but I will accept it okay
[Laughter] oh my God Helen Hunt's top billing
over Bill Paxton it's rare for a 90s movie
for that to be the case that's why I was asking
how old she is here because I feel like she
was very established at this point I mean
she's a really um prominent character she's
like force in this movie if this uh came out
today people would call awoke but back then
it's just a movie hmm it's an actual movie
who's John the bomb Jean the bunt oh my god
dude what do you think that post-crediting
will be F6 yeah for sure
we got some awesome [__] coming our way
what is the sequel to this gonna be it's called
twisters but this had multiple also kind of
kind of like split apart I don't know I love
rock oh above Philip Seymour Hoffman deservedly
so really good I gotta say um we put this
movie on for your Jake Busey who was Jake
Busey in this movie who's Jake Busey I didn't
want to quiz you very Gary Busey yeah it's
Gary Busey's son well okay that makes sense
yeah bud Carr yeah music supervisor and you
ever we both know music supervisors very well
and uh there's a lot of cars in the movie
there was a lot of cars so many cars everybody
was willing to lose like thirty thousand fifty
thousand dollars and this in the name of science
so we watched this whole hour and 45 minute
movie uh because your two friends are in it
and they were not in it that much I said that
to you you didn't say they weren't in that
much I did you not once you never once paid
for a tradition Lockhart uh you know once
matched to me I mean a joke right now you
never said I said I said I don't think that
they're in it that much they're part of like
a gang and then I told you that they were
on game and then I said they were on set for
a long time even though they weren't in it
that much because of the weather thing you
don't listen to me I might need to repeat
all that and I feel like they were in it a
lot more than I thought they were going to
be um they weren't a lot more than you thought
they were going to be oh my God oh my gosh
all right you you win I lose you're smart
I'm dumb you're big I'm small and there's
nothing you can do about it you ever see Matilda
no it was on my list for movies to react okay
well and you won't understand um okay well
I still enjoyed the movie Roxy lay down your
opinions please I thought it was good I mean
it just seems [__] huge yes I was surprised
with how big this movie is because frankly
I had never heard of it before they were talking
about it you murdered twister before they
were talking about it no but Sean was talking
about it a few years ago when I did this show
with him and I was like maybe I saw it I guess
I hadn't but now well why is this known as
a big big movie yeah it's a huge movie I thought
it was gonna be boring I was like what do
I care about a twister for about one tornado
I thought it was like one tornado and Helen
Hunt so you liked it more than you thought
I liked it a lot more than I thought I was
going to this is this is Hollywood fun at
its finest it's Alan Rock Sean Whalen I know
Bravo Sanders just the appropriate amount
of screen time um yeah oh Anthony rap yeah
the hell with him huh yeah he's awful awful
guy do we not like him Rusty swimmer no Anthony
rap is not an awful guy who's that the one
who accused Kevin Spacey of oh my God he's
a great guy I don't know I don't pay attention
enough to these things Roxy I think you were
here [__] correctly
I was like are we friends with those guys
took down my show um
okay okay um are you doing the music I thought
the music was great what I liked too is the
choice to mainly not use Music whenever they
were in there like up close to the tornado
sequence a bit like they just let the um the
destruction be the the atmosphere of the destruction
be be the entire mood for it is feel the space
um yeah I'm genuinely con uh not confused
but like I just don't know why we set up a
movie I think this movie is very well done
plot wise not theme wise why did we set up
a movie in which her mom and dad and dog are
with her in the bunker the dad dies the mom
lives and then instead of having her mom be
the character that comes back it's the aunt
um yeah no I mean I don't have an answer for
you I mean maybe because she looked enough
like it could have been the mom right maybe
because it's a symbolism for she lost everything
cuts out a lot of conversation that she would
have to have with her mom there's a song in
here by Stevie Nicks called Twisted I love
it um produced by Lindsay Buckingham yeah
not an awful person um yeah it was I said
Red Hot Chili Peppers let's go um I thought
I heard it at one point but uh can you hear
your band huh Goo Goo Dolls Goo Goo Dolls
yeah it's a lot of familiar John Resnick this
is a this is a needle drop Galore here my
God um yeah I I thought this is great
Eddie Van Halen and Alex Van Halen all that
Warner Brothers music when you've got money
honey so yeah I don't know why they set it
up but I think you know to keep her completely
alone that way when she's having that whole
spiel now that's why they did it because when
she's having that whole thing with Bill Paxton
to make to drive home that no one could understand
what she's feeling and go like there's literally
no one and therefore where's her mom and if
her mom's dead and because her mom oh did
did they say that I mean unless she's a total
dick and doesn't bother to visit her mom it's
her and all this I mean maybe the mom moved
away or whatever but they never acknowledge
that the mom died right I think it's safe
to assume the mom died in the Twister not
in the Twister but um later on at post twister
probably I imagine some kind of diabetic condition
she had that she had to go through I don't
think so let's see what twisters is okay I
don't I think it's just more Twisters but
with Helen Hunt I don't think she's gonna
be in it oh Twisters movie let's do this 2024
is coming everything we know okay everything
we know and then I want to see who direct
the person who directed this with else the
director do whatever you want Roxy sassafras
when is Twisters releasing July 19 2024 all
right so um when the Twister trailer comes
out will you be here at six o'clock in the
morning to cover it with us I got you all
right thanks do we know the plot a twister
oh my God that's what I made it for plot
details are scarce Universal plan is close
to the vest I like it just I mean sorry new
chapter in the franchises world I hope they
have spin-offs the film is expected to center
around the daughter of the iconic characters
played by Han hunt and Bill Paxton uh well
Bill Paxton's passed away so he can't return
hella hunka come back the daughter hmm yeah
I could play Helen Hunt's daughter okay sure
yeah why not the lack of confidence you just
had wow I don't know I said yeah sure yeah
what did I do to piss you off today sat through
twists I want to see John the bomb all right
it's a good shot to bond or it could be yawn
de Bond or it could be jammed Bond oh my if
it's a guy I would say Yonder Bond oh he directed
Speed oh it's totally a guy I thought it was
a woman um speed's a good one he's a Roman
Catholic Dutch just like Steven Spielberg
um Roman Catholic yes oh and then he produced
Minority Report that's interesting which is
a
Eid oh these mainly oh my God he's the director
of photographer only the weapon so he's a
cinematographer mainly that's why this looks
so sick oh it is DP for Die Hard oh yeah not
at all it all shows Hunt for Red October some
great movies he's worked on Basic Instinct
he got that famous shot good for him he's
growled so fast I read fast man um I'm sorry
and his birthday is October 22nd which likely
means he's a Scorpio oh yeah I don't know
that at all I just know nothing
it's likely means birthday falls close to
Halloween if I'm not mistaken that's true
um where do you find that uh director let's
see what else he's directed let's do this
oh my God directed uh the sequel to Laura
Croft Tomb Raider the Cradle of Life the superior
what is the haunting The Haunting is a classic
that stars Catherine Zeta Jones and I believe
Liam Neeson I want us when you start talking
it sounded like you didn't know but you did
100 right oh Bruce Dern I love him Owen Wilson
wow ghost also directed Speed to cruise control
that's like speed but on a cruise it's a good
one this is cool yeah I know he's cool I but
I thought the movie was a lot more fun than
I expected it to be I think nowadays movies
like this contact themselves I hope Twisters
doesn't take itself too serious I thought
this had the right amount of taking itself
serious enough like enough to give a [__]
about Helen Hunt and Bill Paxton I thought
Helen Hunt was great she was so good in this
and it was actually refresh I was totally
expecting her to be supporting Woman character
and she was the real lead of the movie to
me yeah for sure at first I was like oh am
I gonna have a I like her but am I gonna have
an issue because she just will not let this
guy get a divorce and he wants one and that's
like to me a problematic character choice
but then when she signs and you know she just
need a little extra time well that's why they
boringed up you know Melissa to make you go
God this one was a borer yeah and she was
she was she was terribly do you think she
survived I hope not in my in my head Canon
she died on the way back to her home she says
oh I know how to get myself home and I was
like what what is that even a reference to
do you imagine she drove home got caught up
in a tornado survived but came out terribly
damaged and then Carrie Elvis ran her over
on the way to the F5 tornado crushed her skull
in terribly bummer yeah but you know she kind
of had it coming for just being a that happens
very boring um speaking of Catherine Zeta
John she had it coming she had it coming she
had it coming
um yeah Phil Paxton was good yeah he is very
good they played off of each other very well
I believe it wasn't like Hollywood she's 20
and he is 60. yeah because look up how old
she was I'm really curious let's do some math
here for the constant questions that Roxy
has so she's born in 1963. oh my God I was
close she's she was 33 when the movie came
out so she must have been 31 when they filmed
it huh you said she looked much older that's
sexist I didn't say much you said she looked
a lot older you said no she looks a little
you don't pay attention to me you literally
said Dwight do you think she looks older and
I said yeah you said a little thick in the
face is what you I believe you said yeah and
I thought like that's a little mean no it's
just so hard when people have been stuck I
don't know if you have this problem but people
have been stars for so many years they like
stay looking the same so it's hard to know
hair transplants um and I was trying to figure
out like okay so what had Helen done at this
point I would have guessed that she was like
37 38 in this ouch no why ouch no because
she clearly looked much younger than that
Helen Hunt is married to Hank Azaria yeah
everyone knows that I did not know that are
they oh no they don't divorced one whole year
so will you IMDb here for a second what did
she do before this oh mad about you that episode
of Friends where she carried over a character
from Mad about you but this is then this must
be before she did um later on she did what
that's what I was going to say was this that
was her husband later don't hit me with the
great actors great actors okay if you say
so why is there someone in there that's problematic
[Music] not if you have certain beliefs oh
you know what oh someone wants to install
my Man of Steel movie but will not go to town
on article review without a certain actor
let's see Mel Gibson um I love you Daddy so
as good against was the next year oh yeah
friends of two years before she won an Oscar
for okay so she hadn't done as much before
this no interesting yeah wow so this was like
her big big screen wow she crushed this then
she really had a commanding presence and like
just was so really wait that is bizarre to
me right how no what about you must have been
before but that's a show was Bill Paxton nobody
before this is kind of crazy I mean Mad About
You must have been like a huge ass show then
for her to be doing this you mean yeah yeah
totally totally I mean she's so so delete
yeah in a huge Blockbuster what was the budget
on there's top billing okay yeah I mean we
start with her so it makes sense that she
was top billing it was her backstory she's
the protagonist yeah 92 million dollars for
inflation and to be like like 200 million
dollars for inflation it looked really good
they did a really really good job with this
effects hold up still amazingly like I love
sets where the Practical effects are on like
really shown like the the destruction of the
houses the debris and all the all the houses
toppled over and stuff I thought that all
looked great and um I thought it had a real
it had some genuine fun to it it was exciting
like had an excitement to it it was kind of
like the same structure all the time you know
like yeah chase the tornado try to get the
internet fail yeah destruction take a little
breather they set it up at the beginning like
there's four of them so you know how many
and we're waiting for a five and whatever
like you kind of knew all that this is interesting
last minute reshoots in March and April to
clarify a scene about Joe as a child and overtime
requirements during post-production of Twister
Spielberg took over directing duties on Minority
Report instead of The Haunting oh interesting
and then he went on to the yeah hunting instead
do you think that was like a gentleman's like
all right you do this I'll do this okay yeah
oh how funny wow Minority Report is one of
my favorites that's pretty I'm glad he took
over for that me too I love that movie it's
an amazing film um yeah that was cool Philip
Seymour Hoffman was in it fun supporting creepy
guy yeah your friends what are their names
again oh my God what is brought up with you
Alan rock Alan Rock Sean Whalen Shawn Wayland
oh I'll commit to memory I I wish Alan Rock
was my friend he's not your friend I'm gonna
try well this is gonna go up after you try
okay so we'll see so let me know if I need
to cut something out okay you guys I will
remove anything that is complementary towards
him if he does not treat you nice no no I
met him the other day it was lovely he's just
not I just don't think he'd call me a friend
yet yeah well you gotta climb that ladder
the operative word thematically speaking I
think friendship is there
plot line perhaps not that's the Journey of
your character right there with Alan Ruck
yep oh my God thank God I got his name right
um you know he's very very um he's known yeah
I know he's well known um who's your little
friend who's your little buddy we're supporting
yeah yeah yeah I have I I have a Funko Pop
of me and that's all made um as a gift not
like you know I have an official Funko Pop
but they took the Cameron Funko Pop and then
they converted it to like my hair and stuff
but they took it from camera why was that
the one they used for you I have no idea but
that was the one they used how'd you know
because they told me that's what they did
that's cool I said sweet so apparently I look
like your friend your best friend Alan Ruck
I just call him Al oh I call him AI I don't
know why the eye is there AR um I'll be still
shorter than um
do you have anything else you want to add
no just that this was good I am excited that
I don't have to lie to them when I tell them
that I watched it today and they say how did
you like it and I can say that was really
really solid that's how I almost felt about
this movie called Always Lola
you're you're the shots fired today I haven't
seen you removed your movie all right I feel
bad I actually haven't seen them
I know how proud you are of that people say
it's really good I've heard him private who's
people you know friends of friends like Roxy's
actually good in the movie thanks appreciate
that um pretty decent I try to watch it it
was it was then some random Festival like
Marina Del Rey and you didn't come it was
in July this year are you stating that because
we weren't as close in July no no no no no
it's not July yet all right I said I was going
to come that's why that's why I messed up
there's one happening right I thought you
have I thought you have it playing no it happened
it already happened last July oh oh yeah I
didn't I don't know I think I knew you then
did I know you I didn't know you said like
October right because we were besties yet
we didn't really know each other I would see
you like in passing it like Throwdown events
I think it well I'll keep everybody posted
on how they can see it but hopefully soon
okay cool I'll react to it right here oh my
God every time you show up on screen we'll
go that would be crazy I would do a reaction
with you I'd be so self-conscious you would
be I'd be selfish I would be I'd be like so
where you're next to me and be like this is
weird does this make you feel more confident
that you could live through a twister because
I'm actually now no longer afraid yeah I can
handle the Twister man kick that Twister's
ass totally yeah me too bro get my pistol
I was like totally like win the game of twists
I do strap myself some pipes how hard is that
get my belt I really feel like that leather
let's do this I feel like all of our review
was in the reaction how unrealistic is twister
and it says do you mean how realistic interesting
but is it scientifically accurate okay Fox
Weather what do you got yeah and you push
your agendas huh he was a weatherman try to
give me a vote a certain way oh come on load
internet I need to find out yeah which which
uh side of the aisle is pro twister
laughs oh God that is the cool thing about
natural disasters which is a sentence I don't
say often yeah I say at least once a week
nobody's down uh dodo uh God huh twister okay
Kathleen Kennedy produces Star Wars
um I don't see if it's scientifically accurate
I just want like a a quick answer I just want
something that's just like it's twister and
acne it was actually based on the work of
scientists at noaa's national severe storms
laboratory there was no way you could survive
a lot of that [__] that they survived
though no way don't believe it no it's just
the Running part oh my God you can't run that
yeah no that's [__] no no way but Alan
Ruck could uh run it and so can Sam Wilson
what's his name Wilson Sam Wilson okay Sean
Whelan he's literally directing my movie oh
my god dude and the movie crust is gonna be
incredible it's about a laundry piece of uh
chain yes all righty I wish you listened to
me I did listen Pete's uh crusts is the laundry
laundromat and there's gross stuff it's a
horror comedy I just don't remember names
took me forever to be like oh Roxy short for
Roxanne good how is it like that what does
your name mean was it mean
Rock Solid I don't get the question what is
what does your name mean like why was I named
it holy crap how is this a hard question what
is the meaning of your name in like a different
language you mean
well I don't know what you mean just like
the general like what does the name Roxanne
mean I've never been asked that before nor
do I think it has a
is right there so you wanted the Greek origins
of my name you have a is there another meaning
to your name I don't think my name has a meaning
it says it right here when you type it in
Persian origin where the name originates from
it originates it's a Persian origin name okay
and it means Dawn
did you not know this I I still don't even
know what you're talking about
Alan rock is gonna have a very hard time becoming
your friend I don't think he's gonna ask me
where my name I was named after the sting
in the police song Roxanne were you legitimate
your name yes okay okay so maybe that song
was that would be the answer to why you were
named Roxanne okay like I was named Greg because
of my uncle you you know what Greg means Gregory
means Vigilant and watchful in what I don't
know where it comes from but that's what the
original originator of my name cheese you're
taking the fun out of Twister
[Music] meaning flock
yes such ties Grant Greg this you were the
flock stature of a Shepherd yeah you guys
at home let us know how many of you know what
your name means and if you don't Google it
it's interesting what do mine mean uh Dawn
it's Persian alrighty guys like me well let
us know your thoughts down below be sure to
subscribe leave a like go watch our Prince
of Egypt reaction not as much hate as I thought
but a decent amount just what I like to see
um before we go Roxy can you help me do a
patreon of the day shut up
back to all you Pages this one goes out to
one very specific Patron out there Daniel
Kelly
who would be amazing to give a shout out to
also you've got share in your name and the
Cher is the Queen of All Things Scottish and
also I would let her prescribe me anything
just like you Daniel thanks thanks for you
patreon um what language was or what accent
was that I don't know I I couldn't think of
Scottish you started Irish okay what's Scottish
you know when we started messing around on
like when we were just like warming up for
the camera earlier you were doing a Scottish
accent what did I say um I'm best friends
with Alan o'broke [Laughter] I love me some
Alan Rock uh I can't do Scottish accents I
bet you sound way Doper than I do I did it
earlier it came over me like like the dawn
nicely done yeah no seriously super sexy reject
Daniel thank you thank you I hope you appreciated
that all right this video is official Irish
and you went British right person [Music]